In an extraordinary move, the United States
is pursuing full diplomatic relations with
Cuba, but this won't mean the end to the economic
embargo, which only Congress can fully remove.
It's a comprehensive set of economic sanctions
on Cuba that has existed since roughly 1962.
It has been an absolute disaster for both
the United States and Cuba. Here are 7 reasons
why the embargo needs to end. #1. American
diplomats in Havana admit that the embargo
is a failure. The goal of the embargo was
to put pressure on the Cuban government -- economic
pressure that was supposed to create popular
anger and resistance to the government and
eventually overthrow it. But, according to
a 2009 cable from the U.S.'s top diplomat
in Havana at the time, that has failed to
happen. 2. Sanctions have failed to ruin Cuba's
economy. Cuba has seen a fair amount of economic
growth since the sanctions were created, indicating
that there wasn't nearly enough pressure to
send the economy into a full tailspin and
thus foment rebellion. #3. The embargo has
probably killed Cubans. The 1992 Cuba Democracy
Act restricted the flow of medical goods into
Cuba from the United States. This resulted
in a precipitous decline in access to medical
supplies inside Cuba. According to a 2010
review by two Stanford researchers, they believe
that the lack of access to this medicine was
responsible for several disease outbreaks
in the country, including an increase in Tuberculosis
fatalities. 4.) The embargo has not significantly
reduced Cuba's human rights abuses. Cuba has
a terrible human rights record. Among other
things, it's one of the worst countries on
freedom of the press in the Western Hemisphere,
and it throws dissidents and bloggers into
jail merely for criticizing the regime. However,
there's zero evidence that the sanctions regime
has done anything to make those abuses better.
5.) Almost the entire world opposes the United
States's policy. For 23 years, the United
Nations has voted to condemn the American
policy towards Cuba. The last vote in 2014
saw 188 out of 193 UN member states opposing
it in the General Assembly. 6.) Cuba is not
a state sponsor of terrorism anymore. Some
of the sanctions on Cuba come from the U.S.
designated Cuba a state sponsor of terrorism
because of its support for the Basque terrorist
group ETA and the Columbian group, the FARC.
Now, according to the State Department's most
recent review, there's no evidence that Cuba
is providing material military support to
these groups. Moreover, Cuba is cooperating
with Spain on the transfer of ETA prisoners,
and it has been sponsoring a peace conference
in Havana for the FARC and the Columbian government
-- one that appears to have resulted in a
unilateral ceasefire declaration by the FARC.
7.) A majority of Americans support normalizing
diplomatic relations with Cuba and majorities
support relaxing major parts of the embargo,
including restrictions on US companies doing
business in Cuba. Now, Cuban-Americans also
appear to oppose the embargo. If the people
who have the most reasons to hate the Castro
government have come around to thinking the
embargo isn't worth the costs,
it's time to reconsider the policy.